starting off this hour is going to be
Stephanie in Colorado
hi Stephanie welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up in your world so my
husband and I have a big hole we are 225
thousand dollars in debt he and I
together make a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year he does have
bonuses that you can get up to six
thousand a year and we have about a
hundred and sixty four thousand of what
we owe is student loan debt that is at
seven percent or above interest rate and
when we did our search on your website
it said it was going to take us about
eight years to pay off our two hundred
twenty-five thousand so we're trying to
figure out what the best approach is
obviously we need to do this debt
snowball but a lot of those high
interest rates are the big student loans
that we would be paying toward the end
of our snowball so I'm wondering two
questions one what is the best way to
think about refinancing if we should and
then the second question was does that
affect our life insurance policy because
we'll be I'll be basically taking on
some of his student loans student loans
start with last question first student
loans that are federally insured student
loans do not survive you and so they do
not have not counting an interstate is
it are these federally insured student
loans there with fedloan yes okay yeah
they if you pass away they die with you
okay so if if one of you or the other
you know the one that is in your name
don't don't put both names on them in
any circumstances because you lose that
thing the other thing is if you become
permanently disabled they're forgiven as
well but they're forgiven at death or at
disability so that that's first the
second thing is the thing you had on our
website was showing your minimum
payments
it wasn't talking about how deeply you
could cut and it didn't project any
increases in incomes during that time so
eight years is not realistic in this
situation what's the other fifty
thousand in debt we have eight thousand
on a car loan
we have $1,000 on a credit card a family
member like lent us 8,000 to pay off his
credit card and then we have $1,000 on
our cell phone
that's not 1509 plus 164 is not 225
I have 164,000 a student loan I go up
and then the difference okay and then
164 and then eight and one and one and
one and eight there's only 20 more that
puts you of 184 not 225 yeah you're
right
I must oh I'm sorry so the difference
there are my student loans that are at a
better interest rate than what he was
quoted at oh she have another 25 in
stream oh so you really you're you're
you're approaching 200 three times we
have 207 and so what are your degrees so
my husband is a doctor of physical
therapy and then I am a business in
Austin a software company I have an
economics degree good and how long have
you been a PT for three years like a 78
he's making seventy two thousand a year
doing home health PT and then he we've
started a business on the side that's
covering itself but not making any money
yet doing what PT his own clinic yeah
yeah okay good good okay so see those
are your upsides that thing taking off
as an upside your career expanding as an
upside he's probably not going to go to
150 as a salaried a job on a PT that's
it's more like an 80 to a 90 range and
and he's bottom into that because he's
three years in so you're about where you
should be on all of that so you're fine
yes I would look at refinancing student
loans it's the only kind of a loan I
would do a debt consolidation on and if
you can consolidate those at a lower
interest rate it'll be helpful but it is
not the answer to your equation okay
it's part of the answer I mean if you
can cut off you know take it from a 7 to
5 that's 2% that's $4,000 a year on 200
box you see that doesn't solve your
problem 4000 bucks doesn't so four
thousand dollars the fact that these
rates are a little high are not causing
your problem because your problem is
it's a mountain so we're gonna be at
1:30 but we're heading towards 170 or
180 over the next five years
household income all of that difference
will go towards this and you guys are
about to cut your lifestyle to nothing
I mean further than you thought you'd
cut it but you're about to cut it the
rest of the way the children are hiding
because they think they're gonna be sold
yes okay I mean no I don't want to hear
about you seeing the inside of a
restaurant you are broke people broke
people don't need to go to restaurants
you don't don't talk to me about a
vacation you had a vacation when you ran
these loans up at school your vacations
already been done okay you have got it
let's just do some quick math okay let's
pretend you made 130 and you lived on 60
where the difference would be seventy
does that sound right yeah divided into
two ten is three not eight not eight so
you have a three to a four year program
with increases in income and absolutely
no life we're up for that yeah but I
mean I mean no life your friend your
mother is gonna think you need
counseling she's gonna be thinking your
house you married poorly she don't think
your husband's a bad guy my
mother-in-law
bless her god rest her soul thought that
we had lost it and joined a cult
and that Sharon was that Sharon was
being abused because we were getting out
of debt and we lived and we didn't do
nothing
I mean the kids grew up in consignment
sale closed experience clothing and
we're definitely doing that my parents
have let us move in with them so we're
doing that until February we're trying
to figure out how we're gonna we have to
move out in February we need to figure
out how we can do just budget we can
actually afford it just budget as little
as possible because every dollar you
spend on that stuff every dollar you
spend on anything lengthens the time
that you're in this prison right and
this is your get out of jail free your
intensity is your get out of
elfric are the depth of your sacrifice
is the get-out-of-jail-free card the
crap you don't do is your
get-out-of-jail-free card the faster you
do this the faster you get out of jail
you can do this
you can do this you're smart people when
you got an economics degree he's a PT
dumb people don't get these degrees dumb
people don't work in these categories so
you're smart people you'll be able to do
this but this is going to be an
emotional visceral experience and it's
going to permanently change your life if
you do it the way I teach you the level
of intensity will drive the level of
sacrifice
which creates the mathematical margin
that you need to straighten this up and
if you can go get them refinanced on a
fixed-rate no variable rates on the
student loans and on a fixed rate and no
balloons no calls on the student loans
but if you can get a straight refinance
less than six go ahead and do it four or
five thousand dollars a year is not
going to be a bad thing but for five
thousand dollars here does not solve a
two hundred thousand dollar problem
interest rates aren't your real math
problem but you can do this you've got
the margin you got good careers you got
incomes it's just a matter of time it's
game on baby
game on